we're doing a very special star wars
episode of our show you got to check it
out on December 17th I'm gonna sit down
with director JJ Abrams and all the
stars of the force awakens
Harrison Ford Carrie Fisher John boyega
Gwendoline Christie Adam driver Oscar
Isaac Lupita Nyong'o and Daisy Ridley
all in one night's can be
speaking of star wars probably the
greatest Star Wars trivia controversy is
who shot first in the cantina if you're
a star Wars fan attic you know this
stuff it's the question is who shot
first Han Solo or Greedo now it's an
interesting question the original
version shows Han firing first but
George Lucas since we edited the scene
to make Greedo shoot first fans still
debate who shot first all these years
1977 still going on well we tracked down
the original cantina scene footage from
1977 and we found it's the completely
unedited version no one has had a chance
to monkey with this this has never been
seen we got this from George Lucas and
this should settle who shot first take a
look my dead body
I thought Han Solo showed a lot of
restraint there he really really waited
for Greedo to calm down anyway look for
our star war's special Thursday December
17th this could be a lot of time wasn't
that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]